fondateur du second parti marocain
l'union nationale des forces populaires
mehdi ben barka était condamné à mort
par contumace depuis novembre 1963 pour
atteinte à la sûreté extérieure de
l'état
mais depuis l'hiver dernier on savait
qu'il reviendrait au maroc
on parlait même de pourparlers secrets
c'est en 1954 que ben barka est entré
dans la carrière politique à el fassi
était alors à la tête de l'istiqlal la
première figure
après le roi mohamed 5 dans la lutte
pour l'indépendance mehdi benbarka ne
reste pas longtemps à l'istiqlal auprès
d'allah el fassi proche des syndicats
issu d'une famille modeste il fonde avec
abdelrahim bouabid le parti de la gauche
populaire le nfp flûte bientôt contre
l'istiqlal conservateur et qui devient
le parti ouvrier celui des masses
populaires des villes et des centres
miniers apportant le roi mohamed 5 qui
souhaite voir le peuple marocain
réellement associés à la gestion de ses
propres affaires multiplie les
consultations populaires et souhaite
instaurer un régime de monarchie
parlementaire
il veut ainsi asseoir son trône fort de
l'immense prestige dont il jouit dans
les masses mais le roi mohamed 5 meurt
subitement au cours d'une opération
chirurgicale et le roi hassan ii qui lui
succède à la lourde tâche de mener à
bien les projets de son père et
promulgue en 1962 une constitution
espérant rallier tous les partis
monsieur ben barka à la tête de l'unef
pc la valeur contre l'octroi de la
constitution par le roi et souhaite une
assemblée constituante
le roi hassan ii passe outre le
référendum approuvent massivement à la
constitution est désormais monsieur ben
barka est la plus grande partie de son
temps hors du maroc vit à l'étranger
c'est alors qu'il est condamné à mort
pour complot au lendemain du conflit
algéro-marocain